oh
wow cage
Hello friends and welcome to Rotten
Tomatoes countdown it's time to
celebrate someone super special and
super talented thank you I am flattered
but no it is not me we are actually
talking about Nicholas Cage the man has
been in a whole Cargo Plane full of
movies and a lot of them are quite fresh
on the Tomato Meter anyway all of this
to say I am so excited to share with you
our list of the best Nicholas Cage
movies by Tomato Meter right now on
countdown
[Music]
starting with number 10 Bad Lieutenant
Port of Call New Orleans this 2009 crime
drama was directed by Werner Herzog aka
the man that pioneered new German Cinema
or maybe you just know him as that guy
from season one of the Mandalorian
anyway this movie stars cage as the Bad
Lieutenant Terence Terence has a bad
painkiller addiction a boozy wife a
prostitute girlfriend to go along with a
rookie partner and a stressful job
investigating murders so yeah sometimes
you just gotta be bad although probably
not in a public place excuse me could
you tell me how much longer that's gonna
be
you just a little mess I'm a lieutenant
in the police department I'm in the
middle of a homicide investigation try
to get my prescription please do you see
I'm on the phone
hey you can't come back here you got me
waiting 30 minutes so you can make a
personal phone call
making that clip all the more impressive
is the fact that cage said he was never
under the influence of anything during
filming unlike his other film Leaving
Las Vegas where he actually did get
drunk to prepare for the role more on
that later but the only substance we
care about here is tomatoes and this one
is certified fresh and according to the
critics consensus that is in large part
due to cages quote delightfully unhinged
performance Excuse me while I uh
delightfully unhinged to my dating
profile bio number nine color out of
space
this sci-fi horror flick is based on an
HP Lovecraft short story about a
meteorite that lands near and wreaks
havoc on a secluded Farm in the family
who lives there so Nick Cage stars is
the head of that family and the farm
where his duties include protecting his
brood and caring for the alpacas you
know just your average sweet precious
horrifying alpacas
foreign
always wanted to do a Lovecraft
adaptation because his father August
Coppola Francis Ford's brother was a big
fan and when you're Nicholas Cage you
eventually get what you want and if he
wanted it to be certified fresh which
I'm assuming he did he got that too you
know what
hey coming up you know what okay stop it
number eight the unbearable weight of
massive talent I gotta say that's
probably one of the greatest movie
titles of all time
Nicholas Cage stars in his action comedy
as a fictionalized version of himself
channeling his most famous characters as
he stuck between a CIA agent and a Super
Fan it is so meta and really just
encapsulates why we love Nicholas Cage
and to go along with all that wonderful
cageness is a Supporting Cast that
carries quite the load too including the
internet daddy Pedro Pascal and if you
love the meme from this movie with
Pascal and cage and a car together then
you'll really love watching them perform
together I mean it's like Charisma
overload
you know what I was thinking
maybe we could have like a paranoid
thrillery angle
paranoid angle excellent
like see those two guys over there
they've been watching us right right
wait have they been watching us
I don't know are they
they're amazing together and the critics
agree with a consensus that says
Nicholas Cage and Peak Gonzo form is
matched by Pedro Pascal's scene ceiling
performance and I just love it when
everyone's in sync if only we could
carry that energy into bachelor and
bachelorette parties then we're talking
number seven Raising Arizona so this
marked just the second ever Coen
Brothers movie and it stars Nicholas
Cage as a convenience store robber who
marries a former police officer played
by Holly Hunter now because of their
inability to have kids on their own they
actually decide to steal a baby from a
rich family set of quick tuplets and
while being a young parent definitely
has its challenges I mean it's even
harder when you're on the Run
[Music]
[Applause]
and Kevin Costner reportedly auditioned
for the lead role three times before
cage was eventually cast bummer anyone
know whatever happened to that Costner
guy
number six Mandy
and here we prove once again that a good
Nick Cage horror movie freak out when
done right can be loved by critics and
fans alike in this one our boys peaceful
Lumberjack existence in a secluded
Forest is basically disrupted by a cult
and a crazy leader so Cage's character
spirals into a bloody and rage-filled
journey for vengeance I mean can we just
take a second to appreciate the range of
roles this guy's had I mean from
stealing babies to Lumberjack this list
just keeps getting better and better and
sure the premise may not hit that close
to home for most people but cage had
some scenes along the way that we can
definitely all relate to like this one
ah
and cage actually picked up some
Hardware on the horror Awards circuit
for Mandy to go along with plenty of
Praise from critics with a consensus
that called it quote a gripping
performance from the actor
all right here's our list so far of the
best Nicholas Cage movies but that is a
joke on you because all Nicholas Cage
movies are the best Nicholas Cage movies
number five Leaving Las Vegas
and now here is your daily reminder that
Nicholas Cage has an Oscar in this 1995
drama he plays an alcoholic screenwriter
on a bender in Las Vegas where he forms
an unconventional relationship with a
prostitute played by Elizabeth's shoe so
like I briefly mentioned earlier cage
prep for the role by binge drinking for
two weeks and having a friend videotape
him so that he could study it and while
it's not a recommended way to do things
he did go on to win a Golden Globe sag
award and Oscar for his performance and
honestly looking back on it now he
really did deserve it
I I just want to know
why are you killing yourself
interesting choice of words
I don't remember
I just know that I want to
are you saying that your drinking is a
way to kill yourself or killing myself
is a way to drink
very clever
[Music]
number four adaptation
a double dose of Nicholas Cage yes
please in this Spike Jones film cage
plays the Dual role of twins Charlie and
Donald Kaufman the former a confused La
screenwriter and the latter of
freeloading wannabe screenwriter it's a
role that actually nearly went to Tom
Hanks instead believe it or not and you
know we all love him too in all but this
had Nick Cage written all over it pun
sort of intended okay but here's the
twist we find out that that the Killer
really suffers from multiple personality
disorder right see he's he's actually
really the cop and the girl all of them
are him isn't that up
the only idea more overused than serial
killers is multiple personality on top
of that you explore the notion that cop
and criminal are really two aspects of
the same person see every cop movie ever
made for other
example mom called it psychologically
taught
number three face off
not gonna lie it's pretty obvious that
most of you have just been waiting
patiently for this one so here it is
some pretty big name Hollywood Duos at
the time were actually thrown around to
star in this like Ford and Douglas or
Stallone and Schwarzenegger but luckily
we all got cage and Travolta and how do
I know that we got the best possible
pair I mean there's literal video proof
I torched all the evidence that proves
you're you okay so a wow looks like
you're gonna be in here for the next
hundred years
oh
[Music]
I have got to go I've got a government
job to abuse and a lonely life what did
I say that I'm sorry I didn't make love
to oh God I missed that face
cage intervalta reportedly spent two
weeks together before filming to learn
how to play each other and if I've ever
had a dream vacation it would be as a
fly on the wall during that time I mean
can you imagine
number two Moonstruck
as a die-hard share fan this is one of
my all-time favorites on this list this
romantic dramedy from 1987 found
Nicholas Cage teamed up with some
seriously good actors in fact two of his
co-stars Cher and Olympia Dukakis won
Oscar's for their parts and while
Nicholas Cage would win an Oscar for a
different movie that year his
performance in this was widely praised
by critics as was his chemistry with
Cher what are you doing I'm telling you
your life stop it no why are you
marrying Johnny he's a fool
because I have no luck
he he made me look the wrong way and I
cut off my hand he could make you look
the wrong way you could lose your whole
head I'm looking where I have to to
become a bride a bride without a head a
wolf without a foot
and get this the studio wasn't initially
impressed with Cage's screen test and it
was actually Cher who insisted that he'd
play the role she even reportedly
threatened to quit unless he was hired I
guess he could say she believed in life
with and after cage
number one Pig
and finally pig is the highest rated
Nicholas Cage film on Rotten Tomatoes in
it he plays a forest dwelling truffle
forager whose beloved truffle finding
pig is stolen making this the obvious
choice for the top spot so cage said
that there are actually a lot of
similarities between him and the
character of Rob who is described as a
portland-based chef turned asocial
recluse and while that may just be
something actors say to get into the
part it totally worked Pig got a ton of
Love on the film festival circuit which
pairs nicely with its 97 certified fresh
Tomato Meter score all lovely things but
the reality is that dude is such a tight
budget the pig used in the film only had
three days of training and it actually
ended up biting cage multiple times
during filming I mean what does a pig
bite even feel like
they're not real
you get that right
none of it is real
real the critics aren't real
the customers aren't real
because
this isn't real
you aren't real
okay Derek why do you care about these
people they don't care about you none of
them anyways what a twist ending I bet
you didn't see that coming thanks for
checking out this list of the best
Nicholas Cage movies which is a bit
misleading since we all know that any
Nicholas Cage movie is the best
the best until next time I am your host
Naz Perez and we'll see you back here
for more top tens on the Rotten Tomatoes
countdown
[Music]